really really exciting yeah this is so
fun wait can we go through paris is it
wrong let's hide them i know you know
what i'd be like
because most of the stuff is going to
charity but you know i kind of went
through a few of them and i thought well
you pick a shot don't give my gift to
charity i won't kim and i got something
special we'll give money to charity and
keep the gift she didn't want to
register she didn't know what that was
and thought that
she didn't understand when i said that
she thought oh well people buy gifts or
whatever and so i made i went and did it
really that's hysterical she goes i
don't need crystal and chyna i said
paris yes you do you eventually will i
still have my things i do too do you
remember when paris hid the goat
in poplar barons and papa's um caddy
guest out or whatever the pool house the
pool house was there for a month
it reminds me of when nicole richie
asked us for a ride home on the plane we
get in the air right and there was a
little ruffling under her seat like what
the hell is that she goes oh it's my
favorite oh my god you're like what well
i think after this wedding kathy we're
gonna need a little girl's trip i do
just to really blow off some steam yes
hang out watch movies girls where do we
go let's fontanas oh that's in cabo san
lucas yeah it's amazing i've only been
there one and a half time
how do you go to i ride one and a half
time i landed and i ended up getting a
temperature of 103. so i must have been
sick i've got a virus there not a virus
yeah landed so it's not the water you
have to get that out of your memory
because it's the greatest place and i
remember that the hotel we were on the
beach was all like dirt and i was like
what is everybody talking about it's
called sand
no that was in the
no they were probably doing construction
by the way
let me just say one thing when people
tell you that you need a year
to plan a wedding you don't you know
what i don't order my food from wolfgang
puck a year in advance
if anybody ever had let's just be
realistic
wanted to have an event planner it would
be kathy hilton i did chloe's wedding in
nine days and vera wang still had to
make a
nice twist
nine days ladies yes this is what we're
gonna do yes we're gonna get you
through this process yes we are we're
almost done with the wedding shower
we're here and we're drinking champagne
and you know what before you know it
it's going to be the wedding
and we're going to get through that with
bells on and you're right we're there
love you
you stole these from your mom's room
you're literally the same as when we
were teenagers obviously not only when
it's growing up i know i have to grow up
a little bit not fully
paris has grown up tremendously i would
say in the last four or five years there
was a time that i was worried about
paris
when she had some of the tough times i
just want to say thank you
i love you mom
thank you
okay thank you so much this is so
beautiful
and to see her this mature
beautiful accomplished
young lady
hold on i don't want to lose my purse
and my sunglasses
to see that
i am truly
happy stop and smell the roses huh
oh god don't break the whole plant
you told me to stop and smell the roses
don't smell that one
[Music]
where are my queens
yes
[Music]
you